[موسيقى]
من أكثر الأشياء إلهامًا
لجعل الجميع في أي مكان أه سواء
في المدينة أو في القرية جزءًا من
انتقال الطاقة هذا هو حقيقة
أنك تضع الطاقة في ملايين
الأيدي ،
الطاقة الشمسية متوفرة في جميع أنحاء العالم
ولكن معظمها  لا يستطيع الأشخاص الوصول
عندما أقول الوصول ، فهذا يعني أنه من
المهم الحصول على براءة اختراع باهظة الثمن ، يجب عليك
الخوض في ذلك حتى
تكون قادرًا على تحمل تكاليفها ، لذا فإن ما كنت
أفكر فيه هو
لماذا لا يكون لديك دعوة على مستوى القاعدة
تعلم الناس كيف  لبناء المصابيح الشمسية ،
نحن لا نستخدم الزجاج
ولكن الزجاجات البلاستيكية ، إنها صعبة ،
إنهم آه وهم يدومون وقتًا طويلاً
ما يقرب من 100 عام ، لذا بدلاً
من النفايات ، يمكنك استخدامها في الواقع
كغلاف بلاستيكي شفاف
والثاني هو  الصمام هو دراجة نارية
يقودها متوفرة في كل
مكان ، الأجزاء عبارة عن أجزاء راديو
ويمكنك تثبيتها جميعًا
باستخدام مفك البراغي
[موسيقى]
لدينا حل من جزأين ،
حل واحد خلال اليوم
الذي تأخذ فيه زجاجة بلاستيكية بسيطة
نضعها من خلال
عندما يسقط الضوء على
القمة ، ينكسر
ويضيء مثل لمبة 50 وات
في المنزل ، لذلك لا تضطر إلى
تشغيل الضوء خلال النهار
الذي يوفر قدرًا هائلاً من الضوء.  مقدار الدخل
ثم
ما نقوم به وهو ما يقرب من 98 من
عملياتنا هو تعليم الناس كيفية صنع
المصابيح الشمسية في المساء
الآن ، والمنفعة المجتمعية هي بالطبع
أن التعاونيات النسائية تبدأ في توفير
المال يتم استخدام المزيد من الأموال أه
لأشياء أخرى لشركات أخرى
بدلاً من
القوة ، والثاني هو أن الأطفال يمكنهم
القراءة ليلاً ، المنتج الثالث
المثير للاهتمام حقًا هو الإضاءة المجتمعية
التي نعلمهم توسيع نطاقها
حيث يحصلون الآن على القليل من المال
من المنازل على طول الشارع ليتمكنوا
من الإضاءة  لقد
أدى هذا إلى الحد من الجريمة ضد النساء
ومعظم الأطفال
بنسبة 70 في
المائة ، حيث يتمثل دور فضلات
الضوء في القدرة على بناء
دخل من الطاقة الشمسية
والابتعاد عن
كيرو السامة والمكلفة.  سيني في جميع أنحاء العالم
بدأنا في الفلبين ولكن لدينا الآن
32 فرعًا في جميع أنحاء العالم